[Music]
hello and welcome back video game
releases are slowing down again and some
big games have been delayed for example
forsaken is now releasing in october but
there are games worth your time and a
couple of free to play big hitters are
here for some love too here's seven of
the best games coming in may 2022
let's begin with the slow motion bullet
damage on may 26th sniper elite 5
releases once again set during world war
ii we pick up our sniper rifle and
infiltrate the enemy lines of the third
reich in order to dismantle the axis of
evil with multiple ways to complete each
mission it isn't always about that slow
motion bullet we can set up booby traps
to move enemy troops around and stealth
our way to the objective or we can
simply use every weapon in our arsenal
and go in like you're a 90s action hero
each mission has unique set pieces to
find giving us a reason to replay the
game and something new has been added
invasion mode is here an invading axis
sniper will join your game with the sole
mission to end you this means you'll
have to stay aware of your surroundings
at all times or you'll be the one
receiving the x-ray slo-mo sniper elite
5 drops on may 26th on ps4 ps5 pc and
xbox on game pass i do believe
on friday the 13th look out for evil
dead the game an asymmetric multiplayer
horror outing in the same vein as
something like dead by daylight and many
elements taken from the left for dead
series the game splits the players apart
with one person playing as the demon and
the others the survivors a round lasts
about 25 minutes the survivors must
complete tasks while the demon attempts
to stop them the demon essentially
controls an army of darkness and
unleashes them on survivors while also
leaving them jump scares possessing
trees and even taking control of
vehicles on the other side those
survivors are frantically defeating
swarms of enemies as they slowly
progress through the tasks there's over
25 different weapons to choose from with
more coming later in the year from
ranged weapons to mid-range to shotgun
and to up close and personal melee
attacks there isn't much ammo around so
melee is very important as the match
progresses players can upgrade their
characters putting points into health
additional stamina weapon efficiency and
you can even start to resist fear
outside of that there is a skill tree to
slowly upgrade over time to build your
very own survivor suited to your exact
playstyle if you know the movies you
already know many of the iconic weapons
and shenanigans on offer but if you
don't we're told this is a great place
to learn about ash and the evil dead may
13th if you want to poop your pantaloons
in fear on playstation 4 5 pc xbox
series and it's even on the switch too
[Music]
okay let's look into some free games you
can grab this month and welcome to blood
hunt if you check in regularly with this
series you will know this was due out to
release in 2021 but that became 2022 and
finally it's here and if you're here on
the day i release this video it's out in
two days april 27th a 45 person vampire
vampire-focused battle royale set in
prague following a vampire gathering
which suddenly broke out into a war
between vampire factions we have the
usual range and melee attacks but the
twist is these mythical abilities that
only vampires hold crazy high jumps
impossible physics to master all while
keeping hidden from those humans in the
city below unless you want to consume
them for health and buffs solos and team
modes have been confirmed yet not all
details are here just yet there are
character classes to use and if the game
is fun i'll be making a video breaking
down the best ones to choose blood hunt
releases on ps5 and pc on april 27th and
there was a ps4 logo in one of the
recent trailers i reached out for more
information and was told that no other
consoles will get bloodhunt until
october 27th
[Music]
another free-to-play game due out any
minute is roller champions
all the way back in 2019 a roller derby
extreme sports game was revealed two
teams go head to head to lap around this
circuit and then throw a ball through a
hoop super simple this was added to by
allowing devastating tackles and
collisions to confirm this is totally a
full contact spot things were looking
good in the early previews with a focus
on cosmetics and looking the way you
want and then suddenly it vanished we
were told roller champions would fully
release in 2021 after ironing out some
of the mechanics but it didn't then
suddenly a few days ago the twitter
account was reactivated and the game is
officially finished it's gone gold which
means it's approved for release any time
from now we're going to find out more in
may and judging by the lack of aaa games
available right now i'm expecting this
to quickly release in may roller
champions will be free to play on all
platforms we just need an official date
to be announced i had a love-hate
relationship with the previews of this
game but i'm hoping they've ironed out
the few issues there were and this could
be a great game
[Music]
okay so we're going away from free games
now and we're going to look at some that
are around 20 euros or 15 quid here in
the uk have you seen this trek to yomi a
side-scrolling action game dripping with
style based in japan during the edo
period we play as hiroki who must find
the people responsible for destroying
his village faced with tragedy and the
bound of duty the lone samurai must
voyage between life and death to
confront himself and decide his path
forward very epic fighting is all about
timing with light attacks and slower
strong strikes as well as perfectly
executing a block to break your false
guard we are promised mythical creatures
to fight and the environment will evolve
over time to come alive i'm crazy hyped
for this game because i'm getting limbo
and inside vibes may the fifth if you're
interested on playstation xbox and pc
[Music]
another reduced price game which is
looking very interesting is deadcraft a
survival post-apocalyptic game yet it's
based around farming
hear me out hear me out okay we craft
our own zombies
right now there is a two-hour demo you
can try for yourself as explaining this
game is almost impossible so try it for
yourself it's a dangerous world out
there and to stay alive reed the main
character must take full advantage of
the undead and by the way reed is half
human half zombie the real draw to
playing seems to be finding the weird
and wonderful ways to defeat each zombie
horde there are dead rising vibes coming
from this and some of the sections look
to be inspired by twin stick shooters
deadcraft releases at a reduced price so
be sure to check it out if it interests
you may the 19th on playstation xbox pc
and switch
[Music]
and finally another very low priced game
we were here forever a year or two ago i
showed you we were here together and at
the time it was a free-to-play game and
since then four games have released each
based around cooperative puzzle solving
between two real-life players we can't
see each other very often in game which
means it's all about those
walkie-talkies in hand conversations
cooperations and understanding each
other is vital if you played the sublime
operation tango last year it's a similar
vibe to that may the 10th if you want to
try this on pc ps4 ps5 and xbox so
that's what we've got this month
anything take your fancy i'm going to
jump into blood hunt and trek to yumi
let's end with a question like always
and today i want to know what happens if
you mix together your last two games
that you played to create a whole new
title what you got
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time
[Music]
hey
[Music]